[Music]
now just like we have been showing you
on this program night after night border
security that is national security and
the devastating consequences of the
biden open borders agenda they're
worsening every day i mean we set
another record in march because get this
fox's own bill mollusion he has obtained
a new document from congressman chip
roy's office showing a questionnaire
answered by the department of homeland
security revealing that there have been
42 people on our terror watch list
apprehended at the border since biden
took office in 2021 that's in addition
to the 23 we already knew about so how
many more will gain entry under biden's
massive immigration policy failures
and how many people by the way got
through that we didn't catch terror
around the world is a real clear present
danger we're still reminded of the
brutal killings of our fellow americans
by the hands of evil terrorists around
the globe just days ago one of the
so-called isis beatles found guilty on
all counts for his role in the gruesome
evil murders of four americans and two
brits including an american aid worker
kayla mueller and remember it was under
president trump that this terrorist was
captured by american allies extradited
to the u.s and now justice has been
brought to these families and we'll have
more on that straight ahead but tonight
our very own sarah carter is reporting
on the ground in texas she encountered a
young woman
stranded by smugglers begging for help
take a look
i'm on the phone with a subject in
distress the female in distress she has
eyes on you
yes sir
so basically she's from guatemala she's
only 18 years old she was abandoned at
the top of the mountain and she's
terrified she's crying she said there
were 27 other people with her
basically said they were going to come
back for her but they never did they
just abandoned her up on the mountain
there's all kinds of elements out there
that i mean out there alone if she would
have spent the night out there tonight
it would have dropped into the low 30s i
mean who knows if she would have made it
the fact that we even found her
you know that she was even able to make
with her phone in that last second her
phone broke right that she was even able
to make that phone call right and it
just goes to show you though too what
these human smug organizations are doing
that they have no disregard i mean they
have no regard for their human life and
they'll leave a person behind and
they'll keep moving on
i mean that's a sad story obviously
but you have now all these terrorists we
have all the fentanyl all the opioids
coming into the country uh
all of our resources have gone to this
massive surge at the border a new record
in march of this year
higher than last year nobody seems to be
paying attention to it except you and
and this show a lot of people have
ignored it they've just gotten used to
it
well i gotta tell you sean it's
extraordinarily dangerous times i mean
if you talk to us intelligence uh agents
as well as you know officers you speak
to u.s military you talk to our foreign
service allies in central america
they'll tell you the same thing they are
extraordinarily concerned about the
national security and the uh and
basically the poorest border here in the
united states i want to show you right
behind me sean just as we were uh
getting ready to come on they discovered
a body here behind me i'm an eagle pass
the body is on an island not too far
from me down the river
we have mexican authorities and u.s
authorities
trying to figure out who is going to get
the body out of the river this is
something that happens daily texas dps
you saw their aircraft operations
division conducting that rescue of that
18 year old girl
just last week found a body outside not
too far from where that young girl was
rescued it's a constant battle they say
federal law enforcement here as well as
state and local law enforcement just to
secure this border and it's almost
impossible they say when the biden
administration is refusing to do it 62
000 plus got aways just in march that
they know of and listen to this sean 700
000 they believe got away since october
2021. those are people that were not
apprehended that is what they are
estimating right now in the federal
government and that is a very very
dangerous situation with what's
happening around the world it's
unbelievable great reporting uh as
always sarah carter thank you for that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else